the tiger king watching Tiger King on
Netflix I've gone in there
Brockman you said I should do it we did
it it did we're through it it's great we
have survived it well I know there's a
lot of people that are still going
through it so we will be mindful if you
will have some spoiler alerts but I
turned the phone lines back here on the
Rich Eisen show a frequent guest here
you actually even guest hosted way back
in the day in our first year in 2014
and he was the god they had to turn to I
mean if you're gonna interview members
of the tiger King if you will universe
in tiger king and I a wrap-up show a
follow up show however you wish to call
it on Netflix as it was starting to
stream this weekend he got a turn to
this guy his name is Joel McHale how are
you Joel I am well nice to hear from you
your voice is that velvety fog that I
love to just fall asleep through every
night well I mean but wait before we
proceed I must say congratulations to
Chris over his baby gate that happy Bert
happy baby there thanks Jer appreciate
it do you have any advice for for him as
a first-time father Joel fir for Chris
you got any advice for I don't
understand why I haven't focused on that
for five four three no this is now I'm
gonna be serious Rangeley rich is that
right now people are go you're in for
you're in baby jail enjoy every single
minute of it yeah I'm sure you are but
it this everyone always goes the time
goes very fast it goes faster than you
think and then just it happened
overnight where they're playing for
tonight and dropping f-bombs for their
friend that's true that's true enjoyed
it yeah thanks it's been almost two
months and it's felt like two days it's
gone by very fast personally Joel I
thought your advice would be don't open
a tiger zoo in the middle of Oklahoma I
thought that that would be us or or open
a tiger zoo in the middle of Oklahoma
bad it'll become the most popular show
ever in the history of anything that's
ever been broadcast so what was your
first thought when you got a phone call
we'd like you to interview a whole host
of people from Tiger King what do you
think there I thought wow I thought wow
Ted surrenders lost a bet and had to ask
me to do it so he got the you kid right
Ted surpise very nice man to me and he
runs the whole place and he and Joel
gallon I don't know what I really don't
know why but I wasn't gonna ask and I
don't know if they had if they knew I
was but they thought here's a guy who
loves snow leopards that you find in
vans Joel McHale and which that if you
have seen the first five minutes of the
show that reference will make sense and
I was thrilled to do it because the
showings it really is truly fascinating
and I watched all the David Spade
interview yes all the cast members and
so I was thrilled to follow up on that
and III in my mind they're their answers
did not disappoint
did you hear Jeffery Ross's interview
with Joe exotic did you hear that one on
his podcast Joel it was an April Fool's
joke that everybody actually took that
Jeffrey Ross somehow did get Joe exotic
on the phone pulled it off no no he
didn't really interview him that's why I
was wondering did you try did you guys
try to get yeah we almost got him
because but it was because from what I
understand there was some stuff going on
the face the virus and the jail and
there was he was being moved or he was
moved or he wasn't I wasn't sure and so
if we had it scheduled for Thursday in
the day the special was supposed to be
released and and we were pushing it and
we just couldn't wait any longer and it
was too uncertain so we just went ahead
with who we had and and I'd you know if
he's available I would love to do
another special and okay well what would
you ask him what do you want to know why
did he wear a priest outfit Travis's
funeral that's a good that's a good
first one that's a good opener that's
strong that's a good opener that's a
good oh yeah I I'm assuming right now
he's possibly the happiest person ever
that has been in jail
you didn't even everything he's wanted
and in that he is famous like he I'm
sure he couldn't even have imagined it
maybe knowing him he probably could have
so I've got a lot of yeah I would have a
lot of questions ready to go and yeah
not all of them because I wanted the
interview to be I didn't want to just be
like a lot of life affair I wanted
course I
I talked to each of them for about an
hour and they whittled each other down
to about seven minutes I really wanted
to have a conversation and get actual
answers out not just throw jokes that
are anything I know isn't it because
this is this is a serious subject I mean
and I think that's the that's the the
ultimate aspect of this is joel mchale
joining me here in the Rich Eisen show
is that you know it is there's a lot of
wild stuff and it's like rubbernecking
sometimes where you're just driving
slowly by and you can't take your eyes
off of some sort of accident you know or
disaster yeah but it there is a lot of
seriousness to it and you know I I
noticed did you try to interview Carroll
Baskin as well
Joel I know she only made any because
I'm assuming not surprisingly they're
not happy and I mean she's obviously the
entire anybody who sees it 99% of those
people go oh yes she killed her
ex-husband and they put saw the video on
youtube of her current husband giving
like a 10-minute argument as to how they
were set up and all that stuff I don't
know if he saw that I feel I will do
that oh yeah then they had a website so
I I wanted it to be well-rounded and I
asked everybody in that on their enemies
whether she did and they all thought she
did and no one no one's really
addressing as much how doc ample means
one of the creepier guys I've ever
encountered with my eyes or ears with
repairable women and he actually said in
rate but I was been doing a bunch of
research but
he said in a radio interview about
Johnson Lee and John Finley is the guy
that had his shirt off for all the
interviews yes we had a couple of teeth
and now he has new teeth obviously
gloriously new teeth at keys Donnell
said oh well for the documentary they
made him keep his shirt off and he
already had six teeth but they made him
take out the teeth huh well the
interviews that way then put all the
teeth in and I was like no I don't think
that was the case and and I asked him
and he's like nope so he that harem of
women said really really was bizarre
no no doubt about that but in terms of
wanting or if you wanted to be
interviewed with your shirt off you can
relate to that Joel right I mean you
would you would definitely do that if
calling opportunity I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure
now if I wish we weren't on just on the
phone so I could actually see this
because I you know I saw you on the
masked singer you had that shirt from
the hockey league collection you mean
you were showing them you were showing
off your own yeah I think that's a
compliment he had bigger arms than most
of the players on the field which is
impressive so I'll take that I got it I
got a shop in any way I can rich I gotta
get it out there and it's just a small
part of my midlife crisis what well come
on Joel I mean like so compared compared
Joel McHale now to Joel McHale at the
University of Washington in that famous
photograph that will show in front of
the house by weight I was almost five
always like between two to ten I was 250
pounds in that picture to fifth oh yeah
I remember getting on the scale naked as
I do and I was like 246 and I was like
oh my lord what's happened to me and I
certainly I wasn't nearly as fast it's
Mark Bruner
Ernie Conwell or pretty much any
the distant coaches but still but yeah I
was way bigger than my my but was huge
so who is that I am it who was the
quarterback for you back in the day at
Washington who was throwing brunnelle
brunnelle and yes and then you also had
your game keyword and you had your Billy
Joe Hobart what a quarterback room that
is troll right at Billy Joe used to also
punt and and he he would punt and throw
it and then you had Napoleon Kaufman on
the team who I think to this day is by
far the fastest person I've ever seen
with my own eyes and I don't know how I
remember him growing up four to two
40-yard dash is there anybody in the NFL
that fast I mean I mean I know those
guys as fast those or anyone faster well
I mean I think that's what John Ross ran
at the combine now on the Bengals I
think he ran a 4 to 2 and we that's
absurd
so yeah you saw that Napoleon was like
20 and I watch can benchpress 400 pounds
to know I need a squatted he was
squatting 600 that wasn't even nearly as
impressive as Ernie Khan well who want
to ring with the Rams who now works the
NFL and is the nicest person you'll ever
meet he was 21 he was clean and jerking
365 he was benching 500 and he was
squatting 800 and he ran a 4/5 for or no
for for for something something crazy
and and I was just going like Ernie I
don't ever want to meet you when you're
mad because he was he was stronger and
after than Mark Bruner who was the
starter and who became the captain of
the Steelers and wonderings
he won a ring with if you want a ring
with Steelers yes he did I think or I
was going to say then he went to the
Texas but anyway those were the days
when did when did you realize I'm not
cut out for football I want to try
something else
and do I guess what you're doing now
when did that happen John Oh
that happened the first five seconds I
started playing football come on I
stepped on that field I was like oh I
should definitely not be here these
people are serious this is this is yeah
I'm going to get killed out here and
they were they were really I was a boy I
knew that I should be out of football
when the team the team that night the
team who had the most respect for me was
on skit night what you doing skit night
what did you do well they said these
seniors were like little advice don't
make fun of the coaches because for
whatever reason they're very sensitive
so don't do it and so I was like okay so
I made fun of the team doctor and and so
it was just a series of guys coming in
with different injuries and me so the
team doctor would always kind of look at
it and go you can still play though like
he would kind of accuse them of not like
how dare you come in here he's a nice
guy but then the injury started getting
worse and worse and finally a kicker
comes in you're the big joke the kicker
had a slight headache like a thumb like
I like a paper cut and then I flipped
out and I was like grab the cortisone
take him to the hospital that was the
big joke that was not be really bringing
down the house there at the rich eyes
and headquarters the Rich Eisen plaza
but that was the joke and the players
I remember d'marco Farr was the first
time he spoke to me he was just like
that was a really great man I was like
you never said that's me on the football
team and he's like yeah you're terrible
and now he's Joel McHale here on the
Rich Eisen show again check out Tiger
King and I'm on Netflix and Joel so is
it is it before I let you go is it so is
it possible you do this again if Joel
exotic is available is that a
possibility or we're done I will talk to
him I would talk to him in a New York
minute everybody on there and
where I don't know why I got crowded
which is fine because the Internet the
internet but people like how dare you
ask those people if he should be in jail
and everyone unanimously thought he
should be in jail and I would like to
get into some of the stories that like
Rick Kirkham told about I mean this is a
very heavy subject this is why I didn't
want it to be you know just a humorous
interview because when when they talk
about the animal abuse I you know like I
would I would absolutely talk about that
stuff and see what he would say Joel you
the man thanks the time I know you're
gonna have we go and hey yes sir rich
listen to my new podcast with with Ken
Jong it's called the darkest timeline
and it's about community and Ken the
doctor and he yeah and he knows all
about the Koba 19 and he distilled it
sound really well and he really needs it
for his career because my kids I'm gonna
earn dad points today when I tell them
that I spoke to you cuz they just that
might they cannot get enough of the
masked singer and I know when you pop on
there every now and then it's a it's a
it's a festival in our household and and
they do in the number the people that
they think are behind the masks and
costumes it's just it's so funny because
there is a standing rule the house that
they will get money from me and my wife
if any Obama is actually in the masked
singer because they think it's always
Barack Obama and I'm like I don't think
that's happening so that's that's one of
the setups maybe one of the daughters
would do it maybe but good to chat with
you take care of yourself home again
thank you rich I love being on the show
and again Chris congratulations to you
and Sarah a little little gauge and
enjoy every moment of it and dear God I
hope there's NFL football this September
well maybe we'll chat after the draft or
during the draft or something like that
Joe we'll chat so great
Joe you go that's Joel McHale right here
on the Rich Eisen show at Joel McHale on
Twitter Instagram and check out his
podcast with Ken Jong and of course
Tyger King and I hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here